are you willing to both of you
to invest 1 billion
in primary education to reduce workload
no problem
that billion
As far as we are concerned,
you have that the day after the elections
because we like
other parties
not 1000 billion
want to spend on pointless climate policy
do not want to stop gas drilling in Groningen
do not want to continue with the nitrogen policy
do not want to continue with the Mass immigration
that's where our money goes
and that has to be taken from everywhere
among other things with years of cutbacks
education for actually
I belong to money
all the conditions to invest that billion
you would without conditions
Invest 1 billion in the basis of
I do not set any conditions
I only explain
how I am going to do that in the national budget
we are the party and who want to
more money for education care
police officers
houses
all those things that Dutch people all lack
and why are we short of that
because there is 1 number
gigaprojects are where all those cartel parties
want to continue
waging pointless wars in Ukraine and Syria and so on
immigration climate
all that stuff
that's where our money goes
if we don't do that anymore you can go there
Add 5 billion in education